hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to ed talks you could
view this as a flavor of our homeroom
live stream that we've we focus more on
education topics uh first of all i want
to wish everyone a a happy new year
hopefully your 2021 is already off to a
good start and we have a really exciting
conversation today we actually have the
leadership from khan lab school here
we're going to talk about that in a
little bit after i give my standard
announcements but uh you know this is a
school that i started alongside several
other folks to really complement the
work of khan academy to show how a
physical environment can be liberated if
you're able to let students work at
their own time and pace and master
concepts we're going to be talking a lot
about what we've learned at khan lab
school over the last six or seven years
now that it's a k-12 school we're going
to be talking about how we've navigated
covet so if you have any questions on
any of that feel free to putting
questions in on youtube or on facebook
but before we begin that conversation i
remind everyone that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization so if you're
in a position to do so please think
about going to khan academy.org
donate and making a donation i also want
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that stepped up uh really
before the the uh or dur when covid hit
when they realized that khan academy was
already running into deficit and the
deficit was growing as we had to step up
to support more students so special
thanks to bank of america google.org att
fastly and novartis
but i will
remind everyone that that's helped but
we still need more help especially now
that we're in 2021 we continue to have a
gap
i'm back sorry for that my my local
wi-fi isn't what it may be
anyway i was in the midst of introducing
the kls leadership team rayford
kim down rachel hit a full time lab
school kim dao is the head of the upper
school at con lab rachel kim thanks for
joining us today
thanks for having us
i sell
we all work very closely to each other
rachel maybe a good place to start um
you know for those of for for those
folks who aren't familiar with con lab
school you know you've been head of
school there for three years now uh you
your previous role was ahead of
strategic planning at phillips andover
when you first came to khan lab school
and actually in the three years since
what's really stood out to you is what
you know differentiates the school and
what you think we have the potential to
do or show for for the broader community
oh
so many things so one of the things that
stood out for me i think there's a
certainly a national conversation about
what needs to change for students to
keep them engaged to make sure that
access learning everything is equitable
and
in particular there are so some systems
that have been around for so long even
when they want to change it's very
difficult to do and so what stood out
for me and which still stands out for me
for khan lab school is
we
are very thoughtful about what we do and
if there's something that's working well
we amplify it and if there's something
that we need to switch up we're able to
be incredibly nimble
and to be able to
to make those changes really quickly so
that i appreciate
as an educator and i think
particularly being able to listen to our
students and take that feedback in
and our teachers
i love the
true lab piece of the school in that
every part of the community is in it
together and we all have the same goal
of not only making
lab school or kls as we call it as
strong as possible but i think that
mission that what we're doing here
is
really for us to share out for the
benefit of schools and educators and
students everywhere
and you know when the school was started
there were some theories some founding
principles that we wanted to test as a
lab school this idea that learning
doesn't have to be bound by time or
space that students should be able to
learn concepts at their own time and
pace that they should be able to show
mastery that you know if you get 80 you
shouldn't just get a c marked on your
permanent transcript or your forehead
for the rest of your life that you
should get an opportunity to get that
mastery that'll that'll set you up
better for more advanced things and it
gives everyone as multiple chances but
there's been other ideas around full
year schooling a full day schooling uh
having students teach each other you
know there's everyone's a student
everyone's a teacher that's what the
shirts say at khan lab school how do you
feel about those things what has had you
think the school has been able to prove
out that have working well and where do
you think we could uh push even harder
i think
it it shouldn't be a radical notion but
the part you mentioned about every
student can achieve at a high level
i think that mastery piece is incredibly
important there's so many other things
that kids do where they're given the
time to master it whether
it's piano
whether it's you know they're a soccer
player or a dancer but for some reason
when it comes to science or math we're
in these systems where it's like okay
move along so that
that notion that actually
at our school we don't have letter
grades but for us mastery student
reaches 90
proficiency and
so the mastery is constant the time at
which that happens changes
and so that's incredible to me and
incredibly motivating for students even
the ones where it takes them a little
more time
because there's not
this fear of failure is one thing but i
think also internally the notion that
people believe that they can achieve at
a high level that's incredibly profound
and then i think as we've learned
through covet and the pandemic and
everything that's happening with schools
we're built as a school for parents who
work and so the fact that we can stay
open until six
and have a
program that's really enriching
after sort of traditional school hours
for those students who want to stay and
so that parents can kind of finish up
if if they do have a job that happens to
end late in the afternoon i think that's
that's a great
building block of of how you even think
about
a school in a community
beyond the academic piece
and and you know one of the one of the
ideas that a lot of folks have you know
they think okay khan academy is
definitely you know it's an online
learning tool obviously kls leverages
khan academy a lot but they might have a
a stereotype or i would describe it as a
misconception that oh therefore this
must be like a super tech focused school
obviously it's a very tech savvy school
it leverages online tools but you know
rachel then i actually loved kim's
thoughts especially as we go into high
school but rachel uh you know what would
surprise people when they visit the
school about you know the level of human
interactivity
sure i think i always shock people by
letting them know
that we still teach cursive
uh
and the fact that there's great research
about sort of brain connectivity and the
ability to to master
material so
for us the tech is not the point it's
just a tool and i think people would
also be surprised by
how adept students are
with that piece of the learning
particularly when we had to
do remote learning
in a few weeks
so our students when they got home they
were used to
going online
using khan academy being able to to show
their teachers by inputting things that
they they've mastered something sort of
the we talk a lot about executive
function executive skills
at con lab school so that's part of
what's built in and as you say often in
your book that i think
in general
people don't give young folks as much
credit as they should about what they're
able to do
and so just given where we are in the
21st century for students to have that
ability but also
they're reading books they're spending
time with teachers we're really
thoughtful about how many hours they
spend in front of the screen
and collaboration
that's
even in zoomer our students are able to
do it but i think when you come to
campus and see how much interaction
there is
um and how much time they spend with
each other um
in addition to
some of the time that they spend on
tools i think
it
just speaks to the notion of how
important relationships are
in schools and for a teacher and student
connection
how that really helps build up a student
as they're going through their their
journey of learning from kindergarten
all the way through the end of high
school
you know and i could say you know i'm
obviously involved at kind of the
leadership level of the school but as a
parent of three students who attend the
school you know one of the things that i
i hoped and i couldn't have imagined
when i wrote one will schoolhouse but i
think the school is doing in spades is
to your point rachel the kids are
interacting with each other and the
faculty in ways that are in a very
positive way unusual i've never seen a
group of kids more invested in each
other willing to help each other across
age groups and they genuinely view the
faculty as some of their best friends
like you know my daughter was telling me
how much she's missing her teacher
over or teachers over the holiday break
which is is really a special thing about
the community you know kim
you know as as ahead of the upper school
which is includes the high school you
know one thing that we often hear and i
often hear is okay sal you've got all
these avant-garde ideas they make a lot
of sense intellectually that kids should
be able to master concepts if they're at
a c level they should keep working on it
get to an a level get to true mastery
but
i as a parent am worried about how the
universities will look at that what
about college admissions
how does
kls
i would say you know stack up now where
we have our first graduates this year
they've they've started applying to
colleges they've taken your traditional
standardized tests
how in your mind is kls stacking up in
this kind of uh you know this interface
with the the real world so to speak
you know that's a that's a great
question and what's really fascinating
is that our students and i think it's
partly because of the kind of culture
that rachel was speaking to that we have
of the school our students are
incredibly relaxed about the kinds of
things that they're pursuing and um and
many of them are you know really doing
passion projects and
internships and wonderful things in the
community and and really kind of pushing
the accelerator on some of the things
that they're interested in studying in
their class
but at the same time they do not feel
like they are in a pressure cooker and i
think one of the things that really came
as a surprise to me is that
and the high school is is is much
younger than the rest of the elementary
and middle school program
is how remarkably well
they did when we gave them opportunities
to do these sort of external validation
of of what our program looked like when
they
were doing things like either taking
dual enrollment classes at local
colleges or taking standardized tests um
they they didn't feel pressured about
getting exceptional results and then
you know when we found out how they how
they did it was really quite quite
remarkable
um that they were they were stacking up
really quite well um against you know
against their peers so that's been a
great surprise
it's probably considered tacky to show
off for your own kids but i i think it's
fair for me to show off for other
people's kids uh but you're exactly
right i mean i think you're you know
this this graduating class and you know
what i've seen
is they're performing exceptionally you
know i would say the average scores even
though as you mentioned the school isn't
you know people believe that if if that
the pressure cooker environment is a
necessity for kids to perform well
especially in a lot of places like
silicon valley where everyone has these
you know
very high expectations for themselves or
for their own children
but i think what you and the team at
khan lab school in conjunction with the
students have really shown is there's a
way for kids to have a very healthy
adolescence and at the same time be
quite aspirational you know we have
students who are interning at startups
self-driving car companies at nasa in
many case some cases they're leading
college student interns they're
performing on traditional standardized
tests
you know their average scores are are
better than many highly highly selective
universities
and that's in a context where the school
isn't saying you know
we are a pressure cooker environment
where you have to do homework all night
uh it's more about we believe that you
need the chance to master concepts and
if you master it and have strong
foundations then when you go get
assessed in the world you're going to do
just fine i think that's the other
misconception it's not that we don't
have grades in fact mastery in many ways
is a higher level of rigor than
traditional grades traditional grades
you get a b too bad mastery says no
everyone needs to get
to an a level so you know i'm curious on
for both of y'all maybe i'll start with
rachel
what you know it's been about in 2014 we
started with the powerpoint presentation
there was 30 kids ages 5 through i think
11 at the time the school is now a
little over 200 students k through 12.
we have our first graduates of this
coming year and it looks like they're
doing
very well uh on all of these benchmarks
that kim and i were just alluding to
rachel what where do you see is the next
phase of kls now that we've we've gotten
this far
i think we're we have a few phases i
would
i know that we're we're focused on i
think it's
one sort of growth of the school
right so to be able to bring more kids
in we had a great professional
development day
as a team um really talking about
diversity equity inclusion and justice
and so i think that is a foundation of
that the the work we're doing here and
so to be able to
expand find space to to bring more
students in
um
increase peer groups for
teachers i think that's an important
step uh as a very young school that has
some really big ideals and some big
goals
uh so i i can let kim china chime in
but that's one of the the big pieces and
i think continuing to share out
if people want to go to our website
conlabschool.org
there are some
great blog posts from teachers to other
teachers about some of the work that
they're doing around math and
mastery based learning how to use khan
academy our students even when they're
on tools they're not by themselves
that's group work
and then they'll do some great
problem solving together project-based
learning uh and then also even
again talking about executive skills and
what teachers and
now in the pandemic what parents can do
to support
their their students autonomy and
independence
so just being able to broaden that as a
school with more students i think is
really important and more space to do
that
yeah and what about you kim what are you
excited about now that you've you know
you've built out this incredible
middle and high school programs that
seeming to you know
really fulfill a lot of what at least my
aspirations or dreams were uh back when
actually even when one world schoolhouse
was written back in 2011 2012 you know
where do you see the next phase for
the upper school especially the high
school
um well we couldn't be more excited in
the high school about feeling like we've
really just begun to hit our stride and
you know as you said earlier having our
first graduating class and
one of the things that we have really
worked very hard on in the last couple
of years is really deepening our
partnerships with local local
organizations and really in some
unexpected ways it has really created
some wonderful opportunities for the
school for our students
and for our teachers who especially i
would say in the pandemic really
really became really quite
adept at online teaching and that really
brought us back full circle to
really wanting to extend our extend our
reach and in many ways you know
sometimes we say we're we're a private
school with a public purpose and but
what does that really mean for us
in the high school and so in the coming
uh in the coming years i really see us
extending our our partnership with
local colleges and thinking about what
pre-college programs mean
for our students and perhaps for a wider
student body
and thinking about more deeply what does
it mean to extend our reach in terms of
some of the things that we've learned in
terms of offering online courses and
potentially online programs um to other
students outside of um out of our area
so that's something that we're we're
thinking very intentionally about and uh
whether that's something that we feel
that we can do do well
yeah i mean on both those those points
you know one thing that we've talked
about which i think is fascinating is
this line between high school and
college is really an arbitrary one and
we know that just as everyone should be
able to fill in their gaps part of
personalization is if someone is ready
for college level material and sometimes
we know
students are quite young who are ready
for it there's no reason why they
shouldn't be able to do it and get
credit so you know maybe there's ways
that by the time time someone finishes
high school they have two three maybe
four years of college credit one day
which is going to be really interesting
to explore and ideally some of it or
most of it it can be in person but maybe
there's ways to give access to folks who
aren't able to be uh present in the in
the same way which which i could imagine
could be very exciting you there's a lot
of questions coming in from social media
from facebook there's a question and
this could be for both of y'all what
does kls do differently from typical
schools to increase a student's
independence
so they do they take more ownership over
their goals in life and for their
learning so how how does that happen we
both talked about it i could speak as a
parent and as kind of a a board member
of the school i see it in spades even
when covet hit
even the young kls kids didn't miss a
beat they had their goals they were able
to interface that way they were able to
exercise a lot of independence
rachel and then kim what does kls do how
does this happen is it just magic or is
it something that's done very
intentionally
it's both but no i think the
intentionality of it even with our
youngest students
so
particularly starting in second grade
third grade our teachers are also
advisors um with a capital a and so they
will spend
half an hour at least with every student
individually
and sort of coach them in having a
student set out their own goals for the
week
so okay i want to do some ela work i
want to get some math done i want to
work on my passion project and so we
actually give students
their own schedule with blank spots um
for students to fill in so they can
really manage
their work and so i think that's really
important for for students to get that
practice very early and then you know
the next week
a teacher will sit down and say so how
did you do on your goals and if there
was a goal that a student reached and
maybe it was too easy for them to do we
can help a student push a little bit
more and then if the goal is just
unrealistic and stressing out a student
we can do that coaching so i think just
having the practice of being in charge
of your work and being really thoughtful
about what to do our our kids know that
oh you know maybe i should
work on the subject i like the least
first just to get that out of the way so
that is a tool i think some adults don't
even really exercise until it's too late
so i think that piece is really
important and then the second thing i'll
add is the self-paced piece that you
talked about and so
our students
really we talk about self-paced at a
minimum pace but as they're they're
thinking about their work for the week
or longer
if they want to set a goal of finishing
something a little bit more quickly than
the standards say that's okay and then
when it's time for them to move to the
next what would be a traditional grade
level just in the subject we allow them
to do that and so
students don't have to be bored
right and
at the same time students have the
ability to go deeper in something if
they want to do that so i think
developmentally it's nice for our
students we have some fifth graders in
seventh grade standards math so they'll
go to that math class but their home
base is still a group of students that
are within their sort of age and
developmental level so there's also that
safety social emotionally of still being
within an age peer group but being able
to sort of spike class wise if you need
to do that
yeah that notion's super powerful as you
mentioned kind of age is not a limiter
on students kind of academic progression
but the school does it very thoughtfully
because obviously there could be and we
do have students who might be fifth
graders reading at a high school or even
early college level but you have to be
careful of what they're reading uh but
similarly if there's a height and we
have fifth graders you mentioned rooney
seventh eighth ninth i think there's a
few doing 10th or 11th grade level work
uh but as they need to be supported make
sure that you know they're smaller they
can go into the environment with the
older students uh and be in a position
to thrive uh kim any thoughts on you
know what what do you think kls has been
doing either explicitly or implicitly to
allow students to to build that
independence you you know for some of
these students who at age 16 or 17 are
walking into internships and are
managing college students once again how
does that happen
again i think it's part of the culture
of the school and it's really just part
of the fabric of of the everyday
experience that students have especially
with the relationships that they're
forming with their teachers and i think
one of the things for example at the
beginning of middle school students do a
capstone project and so they really have
an opportunity early on right before
they begin high school to do a deep dive
and so they get the message early on
that there are no limits to what they
can ask to do and so as they enter the
high school program whether it's
internships whether it is a capstone
project that they're doing at the end of
middle school or at the end of their
high school experience or it's a um it's
an independent study that they or a
group of friends are
you know proposing or strong-arming a
teacher into um
um you know to to teach they
they can really pursue any topic at a at
a deep level um within the environment
of the school and one of the things that
you know really is is fascinating we've
gotten to a point with our our oldest
students where they are now coming to us
and proposing classes
that they can teach to other schools so
our to other students and so um it's
really come full circle in the last
couple of years
the other thing is we sometimes get
students who transfer in who might
in maybe it's in english language arts
or math be a little behind
and we're able to catch them up and so
depending you know they might be a few
months behind of what would be expected
for a grade level or even a year and so
our teachers are really thoughtful and
again with the belief that all students
can and really achieve at a high level
in mapping out with the student and the
family sort of let's work together to
figure out how we're going to get you to
the school you have of um sort of being
where you want to be and and think you
want to be and so i think that process
is also pretty unique to us
um and that we're able to do that uh
pretty seamlessly and also i think with
the the self-worth of the student
remaining intact
yeah and on that point i mean we give
the students real responsibility we have
upper school students who are literally
teaching assistants or teachers with
real responsibility of advanced math
courses as kim just mentioned we've we
have teachers students creating
you know a linear algebra course and
linear algebra the college version the
course that's normally taking your
sophomore junior year in college as an
advanced topic is now a course that is
being created by kayla students for
other younger kayla students uh who are
uh you know so and then we've even had
students contribute to khan academy
create our multi-variable calculus
course on khan academy which is now
serving hundreds of thousands of
students around the world uh and that's
normally the type of responsibility that
you would give to someone with a phd and
a lot of experience but uh some you know
we've been seeing some really powerful
things and you know to rachel's point
kls does do a shadow day to make sure
students are ready for the level of
independence especially if they're
coming in as a transfer student but
there isn't your traditional
test or aptitude test and so we have had
students come in in the bottom quartile
of in a certain subject or the bottom uh
half and as especially the longer that
they've stayed at the school you know
especially by graduation almost all of
them i think all of them are operating
in the you know the top decile if not a
good bit higher than that uh which once
again speaks to it's not just about what
you know a lot of times some independent
schools do will just kind of cream the
top and then say look what we did um
there you know there's always a little
bit of that selection bias but i'd like
to believe that the mastery learning and
the ability to fill in gaps and giving
students real agency and autonomy and
opportunity is is playing a big role
here
you know there's a question here
from facebook victoria angelo umedo how
do you do mastery learning or mastery
based learning i need guidance for me
and my three elementary school children
i could take a first stab at it because
it's really a you know con lab school
does it all in in every subject khan
academy is a big believer in mastery
based learning and the subjects that
it's able to cover but it's really just
this notion that if you
let's say in math get to an 80 level
then you should get as many attempts as
possible to get that to a hundred
percent in a traditional model you get
an 80 you're given a letter grade given
a c and then you move on to the next
subject that gap persists those gaps
accumulate and then you get to an
algebra class and nothing makes sense
because you have all these gaps from
fifth grade and sixth grade and seventh
grade mastery based learning is
let's keep working on it identify get an
opportunity to fill in your gaps and
then ideally don't have them in the
first place if you're at an eighty
percent keep working on it and that's
what the software the practice at khan
academy does and then kls is able to do
that in domains well beyond what khan
academy can offer it does that in
writing it does that in humanities
you know speaking of that last point
actually kim you've done a lot of
interesting work with the group at
harvard business school around civics
you know i think that's another really
cool example of some of the innovation
going on at kls tell us about the
case-based
civics course that kls has been doing
um
you know again it's just more about the
power of unexpected partnerships and we
um
you know we we contacted the harvard
business school and the case management
institute and one of our
history teachers
developed this partnership with them
around
taking a government and politics class
which is a
class that we teach in our high school
and taking um cases that were um
being put together by the institute and
using them as the basis
of this course and so it has actually
developed very quickly into a
partnership whereby now this spring we
have some external faculty members who
are in
universities on the east coast who are
going to start coming
and team teaching and are interested in
helping us to further develop um this
content and again extending it um you
know
beyond kls but
um
you know again i would say in in the
humanities and in other areas you know
there there is a lot of power in
developing
um
really high quality high school content
um you know outside of your institution
and i would say our teachers have really
begun to push the boundaries not just in
terms of working you know with with khan
academy but also with working with some
other institutions like like harvard
business school
and a lot of questions are coming in uh
you know a question from facebook tom
lowe our con lab school is going to be
global from youtube ibukan akunwai kls
do you admit people living in nigeria i
could take a first stab at that so right
now it's it's in the bay area you know i
think there's some interesting things to
think about in normal years especially
now that it's a full k through 12 school
we would probably have a handful of
slots primarily at the kindergarten you
know available every year they're
they're there looks like there might be
an opportunity nothing's final for us to
be able to expand a good bit uh this
this coming year is almost an unusual
year where we might be able to expand so
for people living in the bay area that's
i think going to be a really interesting
opportunity right now and then we are
exploring we haven't figured it all out
yet ways to open up parts of the school
to someone anywhere in the world if we
can make the logistics and the time zone
work out maybe there's ways to par have
parts of these experience available to
to you know to the whole globe which is
really what what the intention of of kls
really is is to be able to serve
everyone and then also set an example
that other people can replicate and take
and and make it useful for them
uh you know in the in the time we have
left rachel any final thoughts you know
especially if there's students out there
listening some maybe in the bay areas
who might be able to go to kls maybe
some outside of the bay area who might
want to replicate this type of thing for
themselves or for parents or for people
thinking about starting a school you
know what what kind of big messages or
big takeaways would you have for them
and then i'll ask kim the same question
oh that's a that's a big question sal i
think
for me in this moment
and what schools have had to do
everyone is really sort of yearning for
a return to normal and i think sort of
when all of this is over it's really
important for
for schools and for families and
students who are seeking out schools to
think about is there anything in this
that we want to keep and so in
particular seeking out schools like khan
lab school where
for us the the learning really
is centered with the student
um and also i think we're spending a lot
of family time but for us
because there's all this research that
you know four hours of homework in high
school it doesn't make any sense
kindergartner should not have
have homework and so
to think about the culture of the school
and
the support that they provide your child
in really learning and
maximizing what they're able to achieve
and really allowing them to
think about what they're passionate
about at a really young age and that
that's not going to be set in stone
but i think
what i love most about khan lab school
is
watching kids
get really excited about what they're
able to do and then to be able to to
share and learn with other students
and i think you know the other piece is
time is so important
there are a lot of schools where kind of
the more time as you said that kids
spend stressed out and frazzled somehow
that is success
and and that's not the case at all i
think
you know we really
are mindful of what's important whether
that's a strong academic foundation
being really thoughtful around social
emotional learning and and how students
work with other students and then also
executive skills how students work with
themselves and that kind of discipline
so
for those who are in the area and
interested come check out common lab
school we have an open house on saturday
but i i feel like when all of this is
over
for us
it is a testament to
what we've already had in place that's
made some of the transitions um smoother
for our families than at other schools
absolutely um kim you know parting
thoughts for folks listening either in
the bay area or outside it
i would say uh we have an inquiry form
on our website if you'd like to know
more in addition to the uh open house
that rachel mentioned um we have an
inquiry form if you uh share your
contact information we will be in touch
with you and um i would just share that
you know whether you are in a learning
pod or in a
an online school or in a school that has
gone online
whether you're a teacher or a parent
don't forget that it's about the
teaching and it's about the pedagogy
it's it's not about the platform and
don't be afraid to to shake things up if
there ever was a time this is a good
time to do it and um and and don't worry
about going too fast sometimes you have
to
go slow to speed up
yeah well well thank you both you know i
get undue credit oftentimes for khan
academy because um you know i very
humbly put my last name on it and then
the same thing happened
with uh with con lab school uh but you
know i i all i can really say is um
i set some of the vision with a lot of
question marks and it's really uh being
able to bring on some incredible
talent some leaders like yourselves who
then brought on you know really a
world-class a team uh and you know i'm
very proud of the teachers and and the
whole community but especially the
teachers we have at kls are just uh you
know off the charts committed to what
they do really the art of what they do
in the the the the skill of what they do
uh that's really turning what was a a
you know a theory in a book uh seven or
eight years ago into what i think is in
a lot of ways a very interesting um
lighthouse for for for education and you
know i i talk to
a lot of heads of admissions uh
even college presidents and even though
kls is you know still relatively small
by by school standards a lot of people
are taking a look at it because
i think everyone is feeling this pain of
you know stress anxiety depression is
going through the roof for young people
these days but at the same time academic
outcomes and the ability to feel engaged
in society and have skills uh either
soft skills or you know hard skills
we're not seeing that advanced as much
even though kids are stressed out and i
think the two of you all with this
incredible team are paving a path to
show that this isn't a trade-off you can
have really happy and healthy kids who
also do exceptionally well in terms of
academic skills content knowledge
collaboration
ability to lead so thank you for for
being part of this uh journey with with
us all it's going to be fun
thanks sal my pleasure
bye
well thanks everyone uh for joining our
first uh i was gonna say homeroom but i
guess homeroom ed talks live stream of
the year uh i'm glad you all had a
chance we had we had rachel on uh many
months ago uh but i'm glad you had a
chance to meet both rachel and kim uh on
some of the really exciting things of
what's of what's going on so if you're
at all intrigued whether you live
outside of the bay area or you're in the
bay area as rachel mentioned i think
there's a open house this weekend check
out kls.org and you know as now that kls
is more and more established it's really
starting to have a lot of powerful data
points i'm i'm going to work with the
team to you know have the have the
school fulfill its mission even more of
sharing a lot with the world so some of
these practices can become
even more a mainstream so with that i
hope everyone is having a great 2021 and
i will see you at the next live stream
which might be a home room or an ed talk
see you then
you